Big Mike why were you going to the gym
because it's warm
do you have any place to stay tonight
don't you dare lie to me
so is the story behind The Academy
award-winning film The Blind Side
actually a lie the real life inspiration
former NFL player Michael Orr has filed
a shocking lawsuit he says his parents
made Millions while lying about adopting
him or is seeking to break free from a
conservatorship they set up which he
claims he got tricked into signing when
he turned 18. the family understandably
is completely devastated the father
saying quote It's upsetting to think we
would make money off of any of our
children but we're going to love Michael
at 37 just like we loved him at 16. and
in a new twist the family's lawyer
telling TMZ that or demanded 15 million
dollars from them before filing the
legal action so um I got to tell you
this movie uh this whole thing is is
very kind of shocking to my family and
me because my kids grew up loving this
movie it's such an amazing inspiring
movie
um and I get it you know obviously
movies are you know fiction or or
Loosely based on reality but you run
into lots of problems when it's so
closely based on reality but this all
happened in your neck of the woods yeah
I know I know all of the uh the the
family and the players involved
including Michael and uh I know the Tui
family much better it's it's devastating
to hear this uh uh I know at the
foundation of their relationship is is
nothing but love I mean a lot of that
movie you're right it's something's
inspired by facts uh but a lot of that
is is really true what's happened in the
last few years I don't know uh as I
listened to uh Mr Tui uh say that over
the last you know years so the
relationship had changed I just hope for
the sake of Michael and Ford for the
entire two-way family that they're able
to find some some Harmony here and
resolution here that that allows the
love to come back so so the the villain
in case you've not seen the movie the
villain in the movie is the government
lady who comes in and tries to sort of
get between uh kind of Stirrup uh
suspicion among family members NCAA yeah
and they and then the family over
overcomes it love overcomes it but have
you seen the movie Yes you know and I
got a copy of the petition and uh the
petition that's been filed by Michael in
the Probate Court what's interesting is
when you read a history of this young
man he was he took to the streets when
he was 11 years old he was living in
cars just as you heard but they weren't
the first people to take him in the Tony
Henderson took him in the principal at a
Christian School took him in he stated
his grandfather's he stayed at
classmates they didn't take him until
the summer before his senior year okay
and he thought he was adopted he was
never adopted it was a conservatorship
and it you know that itself may play
into the idea that maybe he did need a
guardian that he didn't know after all
this time but there is no question that
we need a forensic accountant to do an
analysis of this because if what he and
his attorneys are saying is true that
there's 330 million dollars not
accounted for it's not enough for the
Tui family to say oh it's so upsetting
that he would think that they're going
to have to really put up an answer
because this is outrageous we're talking
about trickery forgery and deceit wow so
obviously they made some money off the
movie but they also had a chain of fast
food restaurants they made a lot of
money when they sold at 200 million
dollars and and so the idea that this is
you know this was all a scam I'm not
sure what to believe yeah I don't like
ever like for to for a family when
there's a family fight you know I'd
rather crawl under the table and never
have to hear any of it I don't I don't
want anyone to fight walk under yes I
never have hit my head on a table this
is true
um we had him on America's Newsroom last
week he has a new book out it's a book
that I think that if you're somebody who
is looking for some direction in life
it's got some great advice in there
there was no mention of this he didn't
try to get publicity on it then and I
wonder about how when we opened the
segment we said that he demanded this 50
million dollars from the family and I
wonder was that a quiet way for him to
say let's just try to settle this let's
just try to you and me quietly behind
the scenes and not have to go public
with this because it was just literally
a week ago today that we had him on the
show and I thought I found him to be
like a gentle giant Greg you love sappy
movies
I mean what other what other sports
movies might not be true like Air Bud
remember Air Bud no what about Field of
Dreams Field of Dreams are you telling
me that those players didn't come back
from the bushes raid the game Rudy
cornfield what about the natural the set
what what about I mean I get it League
of Their Own obviously that didn't
happen
women playing baseball please but
where am I the blind side is our
inability to just see how we're lied to
all the time which is how we're light
and the reason is because the stories
that turn out to be untrue are also the
stories that make great stories right
it's always too perfect too much on the
nose and so like you go like we I we
always talk about this with one more
things it's like somebody'll be doing
one more thing about this never happened
one legged girl kicks field goal while
raising money for cancer for Orphans in
Slovakia and it's like this is not
happening I don't know everything like
it's like crime dramas they always like
make stereotypes out of non-stereotypes
that ends up being its own stereotype
like the villain is not going to be who
you think it is oh well it's an
architect
well that was inspiring
going if you like yeah we have 15
minutes I think the shame of it is that
the movie depicted him as an uneducated
and slow and he says it impacted his NFL
career that a lot of people assumed from
the movie and that that hurt him too I
wish somebody made a movie about me oh
yeah every day okay we gotta go hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else